après la journée internationale contre
le racisme après les déclarations d'hier
sur cette antenne de claude cheysson une
caméra et des journalistes ont voulu
enregistrer comment les enfants
d'immigrés vivent ce problème du racisme
porte de clichy à paris au collège
honoré-de-balzac on enseigne aussi
l'arabe ce collège bayonne en effet sur
la banlieue nord de la capitale
les étrangers ils sont nombreux des
enfants de toutes origines dont michel
trudeau ici à recueillir les témoignages
nadia mehdi charles soria puis l'hymne
d'origines différentes ces jeunes de 13
à 15 ans qui n'ont pas comme seul point
commun de suivre les cours de cette
classe de 5e
ils ont tous subi à des degrés divers le
racisme il ya des fois des gens qui le
traitent de tous les noms
sale arabe retourne dans ton pays et
tout ça alors lui il n'écoute pas des
fois quand il veut se commit les
chauffeurs de taxi quand il veut se
garer quelques parents lui dit non non
c'est la place d'un des français tu
cherches une autre place voilà en tout
cas
c'est pour travailler et en fait c'est
du rap
ils sont venus pour travailler mais la
vie qui leur est faite pour eux c'est du
racisme
et si dans cette cour de récréation ils
vivent leur différence sans grand
problème dès la porte du collège franchi
les se sentent exclus on les embauche
pas parce que c'est des algériens et
puis ou alors il trouve quand rien que
pour être balayeur ya pas de français
balayeur par exemple quand il faut pour
trouver un boulot et bien c'est les
français qui ont la place en premier
lieu après ce qui reste quoi s'y
restaurer avec vos cheveux et puis même
il y en a qui sont chemin qui sont
menacés de retourner dans leur pays
des fois ils trouvent des logements mais
il faut toujours regroupés dans les
quartiers et où il suffit qu'elle offre
en fait les bâtiments et le blues
le fait est là deux pièces pillées les
cantons michel père ça ne fait pas comme
on peut voir et on a beaucoup de
problèmes à suivre à l'école enfin on
quand on allait dans ces conditions de
travail et de logement dans cette
presque misère quand la famille éclate
tout craque
jamila vie un double drame la licence au
mexique au psychologue chercher trop de
travail ne trouve pas alors elle veut
faire
professeur honorable importe de l'an
elle trouve jamais on vit dans une
petite pièce même pas de 2 mètres de
large et si quelqu'un qui qui écrit qui
fait de devoir c'est de pardon sur la
table alors l'autre une fée sur la
matière vous emporte vous et combien ses
premiers deux de moins malins j'avais
mon père s'est vue elle est divorcée de
ma mère on s'était montré que le fond ce
jamais à moi je ne connais même pas
évolué chez moi dans mon pays alors il
m'a même pas embrassés
oui
ma mère le cherche toujours pour qu'il
n'aura projet pour que j'aurais eu des
locations le précieux on ne trouve
jamais j'ai connu ma première gérer une
fois les montres ton père ton père et
d'une soeur lancer des immigrés venus
laver mon âge quand il est vous
elle a eu beaucoup de problèmes pour
s'intégrer dans la classe mais on l'a
accepté tout de suite
mais pour moi il n'y a pas de différence
entre blanche loi ya pas de différence
et une personne un point c'est tout